okay
all of this is a little overworked and
confusing when you clothing line
overworked and confusing coming to Ross
2014 hi ash my name is grace Helbig if
you did not know no you know it's
different now it is Labor Day and I
realized that's a u.s. holiday just now
and not a global holidays so wow this
video Labor Day is celebrated the first
Monday in September in the United States
was created by the labor movement to
celebrate the social and economic
achievements of American workers yeah I
did just recite the first sentence of a
Wikipedia article about Labor Day it
also kind of signifies the end of summer
which people celebrate through barbecues
and cookouts right not today I was
granted food item that kind of combines
a lot of the most common foods that you
see at cookouts and barbecues in honor
of Labor Day so today I'm making a mac
and cheese burger if we have a green egg
some sort of like hamburger but instead
of meat I'm creating like a mac and
cheese patty it's a goal we'll see what
happens I always feel so stressed when I
start these I did food prep for this
video I made a pot of orange slop
that's sure to delight the senses and
ruin the digestive system but because I
have recently become way were sensitive
to lactose I thought that I would
attempt to make some sort of vegan mac
and cheese but I didn't get the right
ingredients so this is not vegan be more
it's just um a half-hearted attempt
should I just look up a recipe but I
didn't I just said oh I know what
ingredients to get and Pinterest tells
me that I just didn't do it right
Labor Day I've already cooked some
macaronis just straight up playing
macaronis gluten free super grain pasta
what makes it super no one's told that
it's not now when I attempt to make some
sort of vegan cheese sauce is it not
gonna be vegan at all whatsoever I do a
vegan cheese so I'm just gonna melt
being cheese in a
and see what happens because cooking is
like a domestic form of gambling no but
if it works out booboo new shoes or
something's gonna heat up this saucepan
and head butter which is already
extremely not vegan so not even starting
off on any vegan note whatsoever
basically I'm just making a less
delicious cheese sauce daddy and then I
saw a bunch of recipes that said onions
and garlic why don't we just throw all
that into what are you guys doing this
Labor Day Oh not watching this video
because you have real plans we did it I
have this vegan cheddar cheese and vegan
mozzarella that I was just gonna mix in
this pan with this butter and some soy
milk good bizarre make cheese sauce
anything is sauce if it's liquid right
now I'm just gonna add cheese and soy
milk okay I don't know cheese is in ah
all of your butts and brains clenching
cuz mine are right here um just a more
buttering okay I just put more time
again because it's nothing I don't know
what's happening I'm panicking I'm
panicking I'm panicking everyone's fine
no one's stressed this is a holiday
some people call it a crapshoot I call a
show mashing the cheese is now becoming
kind of like mashed potatoes we take a
whisk
nothing nothing new it's out
it's not it's not so much soft as it is
like just that oh maybe this becoming a
song that looks kind of like a sauce I'm
gonna quickly put it on to the mac and
cheese come on guys it's work together
and you love each other cuz your cheese
your weird cheese flavor day oh my god
okay look at this
that looks just like mac and cheese I
made you you ever wondered what I would
be like immediately after giving birth
what do I do now I don't know how to
handle slight success okay give me see
hold me back and I still have no idea
what I'm doing basically I'm gonna make
patties out of the macaroni and cheese
the way that you would make a normal
hamburger or turkey burger grant take my
macaroni and cheese thought that I had
is that I might try and like mash it up
so it really is like ground meat I have
a masher no masher but French Bulldog
wine stopper oh let's try for mashing it
up like it's guacamole I don't know
there's actually doing
small amount in this bowl now we mash
open a view out there I've ever tried to
mash up noodles not a stress reliever
okay look I'm mashed up that looks now
I'm going to add some breadcrumbs half
an egg maybe some swim up to try and
make like patties breadcrumbs I'm using
half an egg what happened is I only have
one egg in my actual house right now and
I would still wanted to try and get to
that vegan mac and cheese and see if
that works out cracking half an egg and
think this through how does this work oh
my god okay that seems good but then
word you okay I just don't get awful you
stay you touching Oh together this dead
nothing good at all this does not feel
good at all yeah oh and I'm making
sliders and sliders are basically just
like teeth burgers they're basically
like every other countries and almost
sized burgers now we're going to form
this mac and cheese mash in to burger
patty look at that
wow that's food Japan that's a
delightful noise how long were these
patties supposed to be on either side
no one knows no one knows labor day
while our crack packet cheeseburgers are
cooking I'm going to now take our not
vegan mac and cheese and see what we can
make into patties are you prep can
sometimes be really stressful so at
least this meal gives you some sort of
outlet for your stress Labor Day alright
let's see we can flip these oh look like
a bird oh my god it slips on the paper
oh my god what's another one looks paper
hey now let's mix it up here's what I'm
going to doing this one that I forgot to
do in these patties
I bought this real shakers hamburger
grill seasoning you see it great that's
most like no no something going on the
grill this mac and cheese is much more
gummy and I don't know the gummy is
necessarily the best adjective for any
food good luck labor let's prep all over
burger
got some buns cut these are these are
actually gonna aah we're just gonna
grill some buns
we'll be right back when everything is
cooked okay I'm assembling them this
looks like an actual mess I grilled some
of the hamburger buns and I look uh oh
my god
these two are vegan question mark and
these two are not now I'm putting the
toppers of buns on and I don't have
ketchup which is just your par for the
course at this point use your little
spicy brown mustard and some sriracha
I guess because why not I've also put a
tomato some spinach and a pickle on each
one these look at these mac and cheese
burgers oh let's try one but try the the
vegan one first okay okay totally edible
at really great it's really great okay
let me try the regular kraft mac and
cheese let's see also really great these
are a hundred percent edible I mean 99%
edible I'll find out you know in a few
hours if they were actually edible but
as of now I didn't recommend mac and
cheese burgers or all of your vegetarian
but not vegan friends hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did give me a
thumbs up and subscribe to this youtube
channel because we're just here making
it happen
Labor Day I don't know
I haven't been thought through the
actual happy-making of all this